So what happens if there
are repeated states?
So if there were repeated states then,
oh I see.
So let's imagine that we did
outcome based updates sort of then
we saw repeated states.
And all you're really doing is ignoring
anything, oh I see, okay, okay.
How about this, Michael?
Tell me if what I'm saying makes sense.
>> Sure.
>> So if we were doing outcome-based
updates, then basically, you're just
looking at all the rewards that you see,
the values that you kind of expected
along the way, and it's exactly
what you have written down before.
But if we had a repeated state,
then you're basically ignoring
anything you learned along the way.
So [CROSSTALK]
>> During the episode, right.
>> During the episode.
So outcome-based updates learn
nothing during the episode.
So if your sequence up there, instead
of being S1, S2, S3, SF, had been S1,
S2, S3, S1, SF,
then what would have happened
is I would have seen
the rewards that I saw, r1, r2, r3, and
then some other reward that I would see.
Let's call it r1 prime or
something, I don't know.
I would be pretending as if I didn't
already know something about state one,
because I also saw it go from
state one to state two, and
saw a particular reward r1.
>> Yes.
>> I'd be ignoring that.
So what this TD(1) update let's you
do is, when you see s one again,
and sort of back up its value.
You've actually captured the fact
that last time you were in s1,
you actually went to s2 and
saw reward r1.
>> Right, exactly, so
it's like the outcome-based on updates
now with extra learning or
inside the episode learning.
>> I like it, beautiful.
So is that better?
>> Let's say yes.
>> Excellent.
That makes me feel good about myself.